on voit des temps que sortir
c'est un point de passage important
c'est à partir d'ici que l'armée entre
ou sort de l'Ukraine les gens sortent
manifester mais c'est complètement
interdit les gens sont arrêtés sous nos
yeux montés dans des autobus ça fait
partie d'un environnement de censure qui
est à son poids à son comble on s'y
attendait si j'ai une Ping a répété
l'objectif historique de la Chine la
prise de contrôle pacifiquement de l'île
de Taïwan mais si j'ai une pin encore
une fois n'exclut pas le recours à la
force Iwan condamne et qualifie ses tirs
de missiles balistique dit rationnel
l'île dit surveiller de près les
exercices militaires chinois prêt à
faire la guerre sans pour autant la
chercher
vous connaissez bien mes prochains
invités ils ont couvert notamment la
guerre en Ukraine et les tensions
grandissante entre la Chine et Taïwan
les journalistes Tamara altérés Leblanc
sont avec nous ce soir ils ont connu une
année très chargée puis si ils sont ici
ils n'ont pas sur le terrain pour un
petit moment parce qu'on les réunit
c'est correspondants régulièrement pour
échanger pour approfondir et pour vous
informer également de ce qu'ils font sur
ce terrain bonsoir Tamara bonsoir
Philippe Leblanc alors Tamara je vais
citer ce que vous m'avez dit juste avant
le début de l'émission vous êtes deux
orphelins parce que tous les deux et
pour un des raisons intéressantes vous
n'avez vous n'exercez pas votre métier
dans le pays pour lequel vous deviez
l'exercer vous ces Moscou puis vous
c'est Pékin alors ça vous réunit d'un
certain manière ces enjeux-là sont liés
en Tamara oui dans des contextes
complètement différents mais à l'origine
la même chose c'est un pays où le pays
qui se referme dans le cas de la Chine
se l'était bien avant la Russie mais où
il y avait une presse relativement libre
il y a quelques années c'est presque
impossible de la maintenir et des
régimes autoritaires en fait qui
les premières victimes de son s'entend
ce sont les populations mais c'est sûr
que la presse on est toujours une
victime et vous filez pour vous a vu
parcourir je vais vous parcourir l'Asie
parce que vous me fiez pas entrer à
Pékin mais en tout un couvrant ce qui se
passe à Taïwan et en Asie vous avez
vraiment un oeil sur sur l'Ukraine ben
oui en fait pendant deux ans j'étais un
peu un correspondant de nomade je me
suis promener 5 à pour
chercher le moment où la Chine nous
dirait oui finalement ça a pas eu lieu
puis quand on a décidé de se poser à
taper mais on regardait ce qui se
passait en Russie on regardait aussi
cette proximité se rapprochement entre
la Chine et la Russie parce qu'on veut
s'opposer à l'Occident on veut contester
le modèle de gouvernance démocratique
libérale c'est vraiment ça qu'on voit en
ce moment et ça a des répercussions très
concrètes sur Tamara sur moi
quelque chose des liens qui c'est bon
c'est un développement depuis des années
il y a eu des exercices militaires
conjoint mais là il y a des des dialogue
beaucoup plus fort beaucoup plus
important et pertinent et la Chine qui
profite énormément du conflit en Ukraine
et des conséquences sur la réussite en
même temps il y a un an bientôt il y a
peu de gens voyaient une guerre une
invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie même
à quelques jours zalinski zanona puis
oui votre en avoir une
presque un an depuis le début de cette
guerre auriez-vous pu imaginer que
peut-être qu'avec certaines appuis de la
Chine que la Russie serait aussi
agressive
pas seulement un an plus tard même
quelques heures avant les premières
bombes on voulait tous je pense qu'on
attendait tous à l'époque et ça fait
déjà 10 mois un dernier dénouement une
dernière tractation une dernière
décision qui allait qu'elle allait faire
en sorte qu'on allait éviter ce scénario
un an plus tard il y a des facteurs que
oui on n'avait pas prévu qui nous
surprennent qui nous épatent qui nous
désole oui il y a une agressivité il y a
quelque chose de très vicieux aussi dans
la façon dont on attaque l'Ukraine en ce
moment c'est pas une guerre
conventionnelle que de s'attaquer
seulement aux populations civile à coups
de missiles sur les infrastructures en
plein hiver s'il y a quelque chose de
cruel donc non je pensais pas que ça
durait aussi longtemps pour pour
plusieurs facteurs mais entre autres la
persévérance et la force des Ukrainiens
mais surtout cette volonté de l'Ouest
qui malgré les risques qui faisaient
très peur à l'Occident au début de
provoquer la baie de Vladimir Poutine
continue à armer l'Ukraine et là avec
des moyens de plus en plus sophistiqués
aujourd'hui le Canada tous les jours
partout pas partout on s'entend c'est
l'Occident beaucoup de pays soutiennent
encore la Russie et pour vous Philippe
vu de l'Asie devant les menaces de
Poutine menaces répétées
on se dit bah la Chine va peut-être
tempéré va peut-être apaiser va
peut-être freiner Poutine qu'elle
analyse faites-vous des situations c'est
un peu un accord tacite en fait que si
j'ai une Ping a accordé à la Russie
depuis le début on n'a jamais condamné
cette guerre là mais on l'a jamais
dénoncé ouvertement non plus on en
profite on fournit pas d'armes on
fournit pas d'aide humanitaire mais on
en récolte les conséquences positives
pour la chaîne on a une énorme
occasion économique qui s'offre à la
Chine on développe davantage les liens
on achète davantage de pétrole de gaz
naturel
russe et c'est qu'on se permet de
renforcer ses liens entre les deux pays
non pas parce que on a une idée logique
commune au-delà de se poser à l'Occident
mais parce que ça profite aux deux et
que la Russie d'après moi ne voit pas si
j'ai une ping la Chine comme comme une
menace et vice-versa sans exagérer les
comparaisons
Ukraine le même combat parce que le
crâne est vraiment en guerre des
milliers des milliers de morts mais on a
vite fait la comparaison entre les
différents la Chine va vouloir aussi
peut-être récupérer Taiwan question à
des millions de dollars on vous la pose
beaucoup sans gluten
pensez-vous que la Chine se réapproprier
Taïwan
probablement pas quand moi j'y serai
donc probablement pas dans les deux
prochaines années
mais n'empêche que ce que je vois en
Taïwan en ce moment c'est cette question
là qu'on se pose et c'est la préparation
inspirée parce qu'on a vu en Ukraine on
a vu la résilience on a vu le désir
d'aider la patrie de toutes les formes
les façons possibles et inspiré par ça
les taïwanas se disent si on va au
devant de ce qui pourrait arriver parce
que la Chine n'est pas prête
militairement à envahir immédiatement
peut-être ça pourrait être dans trois
ans dans 5 ans si on va au devant on
peut peut-être résister davantage et
dissuader on veut on veut entrer dans ce
jeu là de dissuader la Chine maintenant
demain l'année prochaine d'envahir
un peu confus oui on soutient où on
intervient en intervient c'est pas trop
ce que ce serait quoi le scénario
d'appui de
l'Ukraine les mois qui ont mené à la
guerre il y avait un concert de
condamnation et les Alliés étaient
un peu plus clair sans pour autant
l'être il y a quand même eu des prises
de poussière
quelque chose et quelques heures après
le secrétaire d'État
des rejets de la politique
traditionnelles qui veut dire de
ce flou qu'on entretient là parce que vu
pas même si l'opposition grandissante
les tensions grandissante entre les
États-Unis et la Chine n'en demeure pas
moins que c'est un des partenaires
commerciaux principaux temps pour la
Chine que pour les États-Unis il y a
vraiment des grandes tensions mais il y
a aussi beaucoup de choses qui allient
ces deux pays donc on veut pas tout
perdre les relations diplomatiques entre
la Chine des États-Unis sont pas au
point où elles le sont entre la Russie
et les Etats-Unis si on comparé les deux
leaders on connaît
[Rires]
je me donnerais même pas Anne-Marie le
droit de répondre à cette question-là
parce qu'on ne comprend pas encore la
pensée de Poutine si je la comprenais et
j'avais passé des années à l'étudier
j'en étais j'en avais la certitude je
pense que je pourrais me permettre les
les parallèles on peut comparer leur
méthode et c'est cet emprise
sur la population par le contrôle des
médias par le contrôle de l'information
le résultat est le même dans la mesure
où on se retrouve avec des sociétés
qu'on manipule plus facilement pour
lesquels on a créé des univers puis j'ai
pas envie de dire parallèle parce que
c'est l'heure univers c'est la
conception de leur pays qu'on veut leur
infliger qu'on veut leur imposer
et qui finit par obtenir un certain
aspect d'une partie de la population à
force de traiter comme ça moi je dirais
simplement vous savez que le seul
parallèle qu'on peut faire c'est que les
deux pays sont en les deux régimes sont
engagés dans un mode où on doit
survivre assurer la survie du régime qui
va être là encore longtemps et mais les
Chinois des tests le chaos donc et on
n'est pas prêt tout à fait militairement
donc c'est pour ça qu'on n'est pas prêt
à faire cette étape supplémentaire
histoire tellement différente et puis
cette obsession devrait venir Poutine
avec l'Empire l'Empire russe avec
l'Union soviétique qui l'a toujours dit
qu'il était la plus grande catastrophe
sa chute de l'histoire donc
l'humiliation la plus grande humiliation
je pense que les motivations sont pas
les mêmes l'histoire le contexte
historique de ces deux pays là ne sont
pas les mêmes on les rapproche par la
géopolitique
oui et mais sur le terrain on le sent
aussi nous on le voit puis il est facile
de faire ce rapprochement là le
parallèle est-ce que le l'Ukraine le
Taïwan sera le prochain Ukraine mais sur
le terrain
je suis allé en Ukraine au tout début de
la guerre j'ai vu cet entraide là cet
esprit de résilience on en parle
beaucoup et c'est exactement ce que je
revois Taïwan et je revois aussi
plusieurs étapes qu'on a montré en ondes
au début c'est à dire les formations
pour le management d'armes les
préparations toutes sortes pour pour
résister les abris Antibes donc je pense
que la population elle-même sans ces
liens profonds avec les voix les drames
qui se jouent les crimes de guerre qui
c'est qui sont commis en Ukraine est-ce
qu'ils ont une certaine peur au
quotidien je vous dirais non et c'est ce
que tout le monde me dit je m'empêcherai
pas d'aller à l'épicerie je m'empêcherai
pas de sortir travailler mais ça reste
un peu toujours d'une certaine façon
derrière l'esprit alors que les
Ukrainiens solidaires gardent l'espoir
et
ça pêche pas non plus de vivre en ce
moment c'est fou comment on a trouvé un
ordre et une raison de vivre dans
donc c'est le nouveau mode de vie c'est
sûr qu'il y a des régions où c'est un
vivable on parle de barreau tout
dirigeants qui sont constamment
bombardés mais le reste du pays se
trouvait un ordre dans le chaos on
attend l'autobus l'autobus est à l'heure
je pense que c'est avec Marielle
entre un accident et puis ils ont dû
attendre la police sans bouger la
voiture pour pour faire le rapport
d'assurance même s'ils sont en la vie
continue et il faut trouver une
normalité dans la dans la guerre parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on survit il reste
une petite minute vous êtes
correspondant vu d'ici vous vous
incarnez l'idéal journalistique tous les
correspondants quelques secondes pour
dire un mot de mots
[Musique]